davant
à l'hôpital général juif de montréal
un patient de 71 ans vient d'arriver en
arrêt cardio respiratoire
en temps normal une dizaine de
professionnels s'affairaient autour de
lui on commencerait les compressions
thoraciques immédiatement n'est pas en
temps de pandémie
on peut pas je serais rentré comme on le
faisait avant avallon rente on pousse le
chariot de défibrillation ont installé
pas on mène intraveineuse des gants pas
de masques de protection
la farce parce que si jamais ces
personnes a été effectivement un creux
vide
on vient de perdre six huit dix
personnes de notre équipe
seul un médecin une infirmière une
inhalothérapeute peuvent entrer dans la
salle de réanimation
on ne commence pas les compressions
thoraciques tant que le patient n'est
pas un tube et c'est la procédure une
scène qui génère les aérosols pipeline
est à plus haut risque de contaminer
notre personnel la santé l'intubation
empêche l'air des poumons d'être
expulsés dans la salle c'est vraiment
difficile de faire un code à trop j'ai
dit moi même pharmacie pierre elle et
les compressions
il vient fallu que moi je prenne soin
parce qu'un certain moment donné on
avait plus demain
l'hôpital général juif a été le premier
hôpital désigné pour recevoir les
patients atteints de la coved 19 à
montréal le garage de l'urgence a été
transformé en zone de triage show tous
les patients qui arrivent à l'hôpital
avec des symptômes de lakovic 19 sont
dirigés ici un médecin voit les cas
moins urgents directement dans le garage
seuls les plus malades sont admis à
l'intérieur de l'hôpital
le pavillon k inauguré en 2016 a été
conçu après l'épisode du h1n1 laitages
tice et construit spécifiquement pour
faire face à une pandémie
quand 24 chambre à pression négative
quand vous avez quelqu'un l'a affecté
dans une chambre où vous voulez quand
vous ouvrez la porte que les rentes à
l'intérieur qui a quasiment pas
d'hôpital qui a ce genre de concept
actuellement au québec où vous avez un
étage complet dédié qui entend de peu de
temps peut devenir un laitage pandémique
si vous voulez l'unité des soins
intensifs est aussi équipé de chambre à
pression négative
on avait demandé à ce que toutes nos
chambres soit à pression négative mais
les architectes trouvais ça exagéré
selon eux nous n'aurions jamais besoin
d'autant de chambre à pression négative
de toute évidence c'est moi qui avais
raison
les chambre à pression négative se sont
rapidement rempli trois étages du
pavillon k ont dû être transformées en
zones chaudes
c'est le cas du cassis où l'on concentre
les patients qui ont besoin de soins
respiratoires
ici le port du masque n95 est
obligatoire en tout temps certains
choisissent même de porter une cagoule
et c'est beaucoup plus acceptable de
travail
[Musique]
les membres du personnel qui éprouvent
des symptômes seront testés dans la
nouvelle garderie converti en centre de
dépistage
on n'a pas eu heureusement beaucoup de
travailleurs de la santé contaminés ça a
mis beaucoup de confiance je pense au
personnel
[Musique]